avec une optique Leica alors ce que vous
le savez probablement vous le savez
Xiaomi a un partenariat avec Leica vous
allez retrouver notamment sur le Xiaomi
13 pro ce partenariat fort avec
colorimétrie Leica qui est très cool
Leica authentique les Caraïbes ça c'est
vachement cool mais là ils viennent nous
proposer un concept smartphone alors
c'est un concept c'est pas un smartphone
que vous allez avoir directement c'est
le Xiaomi 12S ultra concept avec une
vraie optique les cas qu'on vient mettre
sur le dessus alors vous allez pas
l'acheter hein soyons clair ça coûterait
une fortune autant venir directement
acheter un boîtier Leica qui coûte déjà
une petite fortune mais ça devient
vraiment illustré la force du
partenariat entre d'un côté Xiaomi
comment c'était en deux smartphones et
de l'autre côté Leica spécialiste de la
photographie depuis des années très
grosse référence alors j'imagine même
pas le résultat a priori les photos sont
assez Dingo je les ai pas vu mais je les
crois sur parole est-ce que vous ça
pourrait vous tenter dans l'avenir j'en
sais rien si ça existait et bien d'avoir
un smartphone avec une vraie optique on
pourrait venir mettre sur le dessus ça a
déjà existé chez les constructeurs mais
pas avec Leica pas avec un produit si
abouti est-ce que ça pourrait vous
botter oui ou non si ça existait marquez
moi ça bien évidemment dans les
commentaires